DAVE: To not be able
to feed yourself,
what a difficult state to be in.
My body doesn't feel right.
I'm getting cramps every
day and every night.
I'm depleting my body of
nutrient that's needed.
And I got to figure it out.
I got to get out of this funk,
and I'm definitely feeling it.
What's motivating me, it's
being alive on the land,
it's learning every
last bit I can,
and it's being thankful
every moment of the day.
But right now, I'm just
sitting here starving.
That's not why I'm here.
It's tough to watch muscles
on your body just disappear.
That's difficult.
I don't know.
There's three elements
that, without one of them,
there is no life--
sun, earth, and water.
And right here, I've got this
beautiful picture of the sun
just shimmering off
the water and land
right on either side of it.
That is life,
straight and simple.
Life, bam.
Damn, that's beautiful.
I don't want to starve anymore.
I want to live.
I want to enjoy my life.
I want to be healthy.
I can't allow my body
to deteriorate again.
Feels right.
Feels very right.
[music playing]
Look who's here.
The main reason I'm tapping out
is I'm taking care of my body,
straight and simple.
After Patagonia, my
journey was interrupted.
There was like
months, three months,
where it was difficult
to digest food.
That was like, oh, I
can push myself too far.
Oh, OK, got to be aware
of my physical well-being.
I don't want that
to happen here.
I want to just sort of walk
right into the next step,
and right now, it feels
perfect, feels good.
Two completely
different tap outs.
This one definitely
feels better.
It was much nicer to take
myself out of the picture,
much easier, much
more empowering.
It's not in me to
push myself like I
did in Patagonia anymore.
That is not in me.
That is not what I want.
I did my best, and I'm proud
of everything I've done,
and I am happy.
I definitely think this
go around has changed me.
I think it's helped me
to look at myself in more
of a responsible manner
and look at my actions
with more understanding of--
I do have an effect
on the world.
What do I need to do to
make that a positive effect?